this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here the
game stocks debacle captivated the world
because
it showed that apps like robin hood have
given us normies a collective and
unprecedented power and influence over
the stock market
until it didn't robin hood interactive
brokers and i believe e-trade came out
and we're limiting
the ability to buy stocks through their
app so limiting going after gamestop
amongst the chaos and to the outrage of
its users robin hood and other apps like
weeble and td ameritrade
temporarily stopped people from being
able to buy shares of certain companies
after this happened subreddit wall
street bets tweeted an
outrage that individual investors are
being stripped of their ability to trade
on the robin hood app meanwhile hedge
funds and institutional investors can
continue to trade as normal
a lawsuit was filed accusing robin hood
of purposefully willfully and knowingly
removing the stack gme from its trading
platform in the midst of an
unprecedented stock rise
thereby deprived retail investors of the
ability to invest in the open market
this all raises some pretty cool
questions robinhood promises to
democratize finance to put
power in the hands of the people but
does it really
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on robinhood what went wrong
and before we continue i want to shout
out this week's sponsor
keeps i understand that losing your hair
can become a major insecurity
but luckily we live in 2021 where
science can help
keeps is an affordable treatment plan
designed to help you keep your hair
get it with keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get their fda approved hair
loss medication shipped
right to your door they make it easy and
deliver your medication every three
months so you don't even have to go to
the pharmacy
prevention is the key to stopping hair
loss so the sooner you act the more hair
you can save
find out why keep says more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
hundreds of thousands of men trust keeps
for their hair loss prevention
medication
by going to keeps.com wisecrack if you
use our link you can get 50
off your first box now back to the show
scholars
journalists and finance nerds alike
argue that trading apps like robinhood
make investing money accessible to
everyone
it's even in robinhood's mission
statement to democratize
finance and to do it for free in the
pre-app days it wasn't possible to go to
war with a hedge fund from the comforts
of your home before the popularity of
trading apps and online brokerages like
e-trade
the small percentage of people who
wanted to invest and buy individual
stocks would have to go to a library
read up on finance and research company
financial reports to help them decide
what stocks to buy
day traders would call up voice brokers
who were either on the floor of the
stock exchange or had access to
expensive stock ticker machines called
quotrons
and asked them to execute the trades for
a fee in some places like the new york
stock exchange you can still shout such
requests at your broker
but most people don't have time for that
in short the ability to buy a stock for
four dollars and sell it for five
dollars on the same day
was pretty rare for the normal
population and often reserved for the
pros
most normal people who invested in the
market went through an institutional
investor
an organization specializing in
investing other people's money they
would manage a diversified stack
portfolio for you
if you're lucky enough to have a 401k it
probably works like this
but most institutional investors require
you to put in a minimum amount of money
usually in the thousands rendering them
inaccessible to lots of people
basically if you wanted to go to the
moon with an individual stock at this
point
you needed a solid stack of cash no
offense but you wouldn't have been and
still
aren't of interest to many traditional
brokers as a client because small
investments usually don't bring in big
commissions and of course
there were people like jordan belfort
running around taking your money to
invest in penny stocks
you mailed in my company a postcard a
few weeks back requesting information on
penny stocks that had
huge upside potential with very little
downside risk does that ring a bell but
with the advent of apps like robinhood
people are suddenly able to build their
own portfolios and invest in whatever
they want with a tap on a screen
want to buy 1 18th of a share of amazon
and see what happens
go ahead want to spend your last 5.52
cents
on your friends buddies uncle's weed
company that just went public just swipe
up to confirm
with trades like this being so easy the
number of individual investors also
called
retail investors increased dramatically
in the past 10 years alone the percent
of equity trading volume by retail
investors nearly
doubled from 10.1 percent to 19.5
percent and with trading commissions
going out the window
on places like fidelity e-trade and
robin hood it's easier than ever to take
a shot at day trading or
dump your spare change into the clever
crevice stock this is
all well and good but you may have
wondered how exactly does robinhood make
money when it's letting you trade for
free the answer lies in something called
payment for order flow and an
explanation of it can help us understand
that in spite of
democratizing finance robinhood's
primary customers are the exact same big
financial players they are quote unquote
disrupting payment for order flow is
when big financial institutions also
called
market makers pay robinhood for the
privilege of handling your transaction
basically for a fee robinhood routes
your order information
through a hedge fund to execute the
trade instead of sending it directly to
a stock exchange
think of order flow as a bunch of moving
traffic
your order leaves the robinhood app and
heads towards its final destination the
stock market
in an ideal world we all want to get to
the destination in the quickest way
possible
but instead of doing that big trading
firm or hedge fund will pay to have the
traffic diverted through them
first this might seem fine and good like
a traffic conductor merely directing
some cars to where they need to go
but it's maybe more accurate to think of
it as set conductor diverting cars to a
parking garage where their buddies can
promptly rip off the drivers
okay maybe a little extreme but it's
important to remember that every
transaction in the stock market has some
theoretical winner
and loser that is to say the buyer
either bought the stock for what it's
actually worth or the
seller should have gotten more money
when hedge funds go against hedge funds
it's like a complicated math war to find
information nobody has
and buy stocks that are undervalued or
at least sell
overvalued stock to some sucker who
doesn't know any better
and that sucker is probably you as the
wall street journal notes of companies
who use payment for order flow
they are willing to pay for order flow
from online brokerages because they are
less likely to lose money trading
against individual investors than on an
exchange
where traders tend to be larger and more
sophisticated that is
you are less sophisticated aka money
dumb
it is quite literally like when your
older brother told you your foil pokemon
card was worth one dollar
bought it from you and flipped it for
fifty dollars while you might have cried
and said it wasn't fair
you also learned a timeless lesson about
the inner workings of capitalism
congratulations in the case of robin
hood they direct your order to someone
like citadel capital
who knows they can get the stocks you
want for a few cents cheaper and sell it
to you
splitting the profit with robinhood a
few cents off every order
might not seem like a big deal and when
compared to a six or seven dollar
trading fee
it might even seem like a good deal but
the ethics of it are still
pretty sus so you're stealing
uh no no you don't understand it's uh
it's very complicated payment for order
flow was pioneered by one
bernie madoff you know the ponzi scheme
guy it's
literally how he made his fortune before
the aforementioned ponzi stuff
madoff made his name through bernard
madoff investment securities which bond
sold stocks on behalf of brokerage firms
to encourage orders to come his way
his firm would pay brokers a fee usually
brokers with
large bases of relatively
unsophisticated retail clients
now if stock trading is sophisticated 3d
chess payment for order flow
lets your opponent know what your move
is ahead of time the key to the stock
market for hedge fund managers is
knowing things
other people don't specifically by
getting in a stock when it's still
priced low before everyone else figures
out how valuable it is thus driving up
the price
in the case of payment for order flow
the orders of you or the wall street
bets crowd
are known to market makers literally
before they happen
that right there is valuable information
to big hedge funds who can know what
large groups of people are investing in
before they actually do
a harvard law review article from 1994
notes concerns that the practice
distorts incentives for brokers to serve
the best interest of you
the investor there were also concerns
that it perverted the basic logic of the
market
specifically that the practice might
foster oligopolistic concentration
within the market of brokers and dealers
during a senate hearing about our boy
bernie one professor testified that the
way madoff used payment for order really
wasn't all that different from the way
he lured
feeder funds into his ponzi scheme it
would not have been beyond him
to pay the feeder funds under the table
because
for decades he had paid brokers to
direct order flow to him
and the two are not that functionally
different in a letter about the robin
hood game stock fiasco
elizabeth warren notes that regulators
have criticized the behavior as a
conflict of interest
while another called it legalized
bribery and
as warren notes citadel invested two
billion dollars in melvin capital which
famously lost
over four billion dollars in shorting
gamestop providing a very clear conflict
of interest between citadel and its
business partner robin hood
the chairman of the sec talked openly
about his disdain for the practice as
far back as 2001
but admitted it would be seemingly
impossible to ban i am not
a great proponent of payment for order
flow it's
always troubled me the imperfect
solution he thought
was to openly disclose the practice to
customers there is no
possible way really that we could
effectively ban that kind of
reciprocity uh
i don't like it and i think the best way
to respond to it
is by seeing to it that it is disclosed
anyway in december the sec fined robin
hood 65 million dollars for not
disclosing this to customers between
2015
and 2018 because even though payment for
order flow is legal
it's regulated so it's only legal to
accept payment if the third-party
brokers are buying and selling at rates
better than or the same as the stock
exchange and it must inform its clients
in writing
robinhood had really high order flow
rates and never informed its users it
was doing this
and that information is still buried in
the fine print of the thing you hit
agree on the sec said it found that
robin had deprived
customers of 34.1 million dollars
through its payment for order flow
practices
and just for the record plenty of people
think it should be flat out illegal
and have been fighting against it since
madoff started doing it saul gets us to
the basic truth
robin hood's real customers aren't its
users its real customers
are hedge funds like citadel the
investors like you
are simply the product which brings us
to the second sad reality of robin hood
you're just not as smart as you think
you are and neither am i
part two you suck i'm just kidding we we
love you
study after study shows that even the
savviest investor
can't perform better than the stock
market average around 6.8 percent
adjusted for inflation and sure
people do better than that some years
but they also do a lot worse during
other years
warren buffett famously wagered a
million dollars that no hedge fund could
outperform the market
and he won to put your dreams of getting
wildly rich from day trading in context
bernie madoff drew suspicion for
consistently paying out returns of 10
or above every year which before the
ponzi scheme unraveled
some people thought was too good to be
true he identified numerous red flags
returns that were too good to be true
consistent gains over 10
every year in bull and bear markets
alike which is to say
remember that magical number when some
friend tells you about some
totally legit opportunity that will
double your money they're coming to hear
kyle talk
about how he turned 15 000 into over 3
million
the point is picking individual stocks
is totally your personal prerogative
and might even work out for you but
statistically it's a very bad idea no
matter how many youtube ads you see of
dudes and ferraris
but robinhood plays on these dreams by
making a user interface that treats
investing like a very fun game
sociologist adam hayes and a host of
other scholars argue that this user
interface is intentional it's designed
to encourage
trading rather than discipline because
that's how these apps make money
robinho doesn't care if you win or lose
your stimulus check because it makes
bank by skimming a few pennies off every
trade you make
hayes suggests that these apps
purposefully exploit human propensities
to over
trade playing upon emotions like fear
and greed and the thrill of gambling
one study found that active customers on
average check the robinhood app
10 times per day often because they're
spammed with push notifications
and for the average user the more you
trade the worse you'll probably do
as we're beholden to so many
psychological traps while making trades
that just aren't smart financial
decisions robin is designed to keep you
pouring money in so that it can keep
profiting off of your trades
you get congratulated with confetti
every time you invest
you get free stocks when you sign up and
refer friends
every time you buy or sell anything you
get notifications with fun emojis and
exclamation points
actually this sounds awesome give me a
second
daddy's gonna be rich robin and founder
beiju ba
defends it pretty bluntly saying it
shares some of the mechanics with
gambling activities but the reason it's
different is because on average
you will make money through investment
in the stock market well if you go to
the casino on average
you lose money and that makes sense if
i'm using robinhood to buy safe index
funds
but not so much when i learn what
options trading is
and lose tens of thousands of dollars
which if wall street bets is any
indication
happens all the time in one case a
reddit user managed to turn
five thousand dollars into a negative
fifty eight thousand dollar balance
thanks to something called a box spread
which he thought was a sure thing
twenty-year-old alex kearns took his
life after robinhood's easy access to
options trading went south he mistakenly
believed he owed the company seven
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
after making some bad trades but it's
still better than not being able to
invest at all
right right i'm i need to delete that
app immediately
fraud fraud alert i didn't my kid did it
[ __ ] kids
you could make that case but the apps
that giveth
can just as easily taketh away and they
do
even though better alternatives might
not seem obvious it's at least
important to see through the bulk that
this well-financed startup company
really has your interest in mind or
cares about anything resembling
democratic finance aside from a maybe
once in a lifetime victory for the
gamestone crowd
what's clear is that the game is rigged
individual investors still need to rely
on these platforms to execute their
trades but these platforms are beholden
to the market makers and the system
itself until we figure something else
out it seems like the hedge funds
will always win but what do you guys
think
do the pros of robin hood outweigh the
cons or are we all
destined to be suckers let us know in
the comments
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support hit that subscribe button like
you're clicking delete on your robinhood
account
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
okay username santa claus
of datscrilla 420 that works
oh my i'm gonna be so rich never going
back to the studio again